[Applause]
is the most powerful and comprehensive
border wall structure anywhere in the
world it's got technology that nobody
would even believe between sensors and
cameras and everything else my
administration has done more than any
Administration in history to secure our
southern border our border has never
been more secure I think Doug can tell
you that anybody at this table can tell
you that it's never even been close the
numbers now including not only the wall
the wall has helped a lot where we have
that 200 miles to 12 and now 220 thank
you very much everybody great to be here
using our emergency public health
authorities we prevented a coronavirus
catastrophe on the southern border
shutting down human smuggling and
swiftly returning the crosses we call
them crosses they cross now we bring
them right back in the old days it would
take years to get him back he wouldn't
get him back other administration's like
the previous administration essentially
didn't bring them back without these
public health measures the southern
border would be a global epicenter of
the viral transmission hello Brandon
what are you doing sitting back I've
never seen that before well looking at
it we'll work it out with Doc I think
good things are happening with dr.
they resubmit but we'll work it out and
the Democrats have been playing with
doctor for years and they haven't done
anything
I'll get it done and we'll good things
will happen for daca recipients
pretty soon mister would ya put your
chin up good things are going to happen